all right Kristen Kristen Oh where'd you
grow up where you from originally I was
nine former Texas I came out here my mom
decided to find my dad and I came out
here when I was about two years old mom
got into a heroin addiction and never
left so you came down to skid row it at
what age I was two and I came down here
to I grew up down here sad to say zone
and how was your childhood just
functional very very dysfunctional
Robert my dad was the drug dealer my mom
was a prostitute
I got sold into prostitution by my mom
to support her habit so yeah what age I
was 11 my mom sold me powder start of
1996 Wow
what is that like for a young girl to
start doing that scary
it's depressing you know it's you know
once you fit into that life I was into
20 years before I was finally able to
make my break and some girls never make
a break so I mean this life will scar
you in ways you never see coming
and so how was your relationship with
your mother relationship I mean even
though she did what she did she was
still my best friend
we talked about everything did
everything together
did she saw huh my mom committed suicide
20 years ago and how old were you then I
was 14 so 14 you're on your own down
here where it was dead did dad come into
the picture
no I my dad was didn't have to face your
long before that um my dad did 17 years
in the penitentiary for Shawn armed
robbery attempted murder so I never
really got something my dad up until a
couple years ago but I'm gonna talk
about mom died I was pretty much on my
own I mean my grandpa was there he's my
hero
he took on me my brothers and sisters
so you went to your grandparents after
your mom died I went to my grandpa I
never knew my grandma died even left my
mom boys I never got to no one but my
Grandpop is what hero fit he took on a
lot of kids badass kids too
we were a rough Bunch so today you're
living in a tent I'm living it seems I'm
not gonna have from here and what are
you doing for money now um what have you
done that I can without getting it's no
legal troubles well what have you done
for money over the year
prostitute in the part-time drug to you
there I've been enforcer for some of the
dealers down here all the things and
people don't want to do I've done
what is your drug today I'm a Christmas
crystal meth do for you at this point
cuz even even doing it for how long I
mean since I was 13 well it's just a bee
it's just like another person is smoking
a cigarette it's just it's a comfort
it's a it's a social joke I don't like
to smoke by myself and otherwise I'm a
pretty introverted person I don't I
don't hang out with everybody I don't
mess with everybody so it's my way to be
social and not be a complete Wallflower
it makes me makes you more extroverted
yeah it makes you more extroverted yeah
and then what even down here for decades
and decades what what have you I'm sure
you have seen some crazy things I've
seen people by driving for potties Craig
I've seen bodies fly out of windows 12
and 13 stories up I've seen countless
suicides at the frontier hotel yep right
here to find out injuries Rossum they
all used to be bad real bad
I've seen I've seen people be killed
I've seen stabbed be just less sure my
best friend's was beaten and stabbed to
live down here on San Jose what what was
the lowest point in your life I would
say the lowest bring in my life today my
youngest daughter was born she was born
with human feces in her lungs and it was
behind crystal meth addiction before -
she caught up in getting high being
popular
- pipe down so so you didn't raise her
you lost us she never came home from the
hospital she went straight into a doctor
Sam how many kids do you have I have six
kids and two grandkids did you raise
your kids any oh um the last the last
one to be born I didn't have any any
hand and her raising but the other five
I had been for write partial talk to my
wife I did did you do I mean do you ever
talk to your kids now I haven't talked
to my kids it's 2013 did you see a
connection between like the the
childhood that you had that was it's a
repetitive cycle a difficult right into
your life today it is it's very
repetitive cycle yeah the role models
you had
the environment is the pimps and hoes
and it's still even not being in that
life I can't shake it I can't shake the
consequences beginning if there is
anything about your life you could have
could have changed what would that be
it's a good question
and we would having so many things I
would change I can find just one but I
think the biggest one I would change is
never picking up a bike
and then also last time you mentioned
having a dad in your life yeah my life
um it's hard for a girl not have an
internet because of the the education
and all the lessons that we're supposed
to learn about how to pick a good guy
later on in life you know most girls
learned that lesson from their dead
watching their dad and I can't say that
I did
I will even if I would have had my dad
in my life as a kid I'm going a little
bit different today what kind of dad
what kind of guys do you end up digging
up with now joint ears abuse guy said
don't really want nothing in life but to
meet ghetto famous
did you ever give any hope of getting
clean and getting off the street
logically part of me wants to say yeah I
do and in reality at this point in my
froggy nein do you think give you down
here for the rest of your life yeah
you know here so long it becomes so
and nobody really wants to leave home
all right Kristin thank you so much for
talking to me
thank you good luck with everything
thank you such a crybaby
you